because virtually every single one of
your forecasts on the future of the
economy during this present government
has been wrong hasn't it you forecast
that unemployment would rise you
forecast that wages would fall one point
I think you even forecast the inflation
would rise in places now at zero wages
have fallen people are 1600 pounds of
you're worse off than they were when
they these government came to power it's
the worst record on living standard
since the 1920s and that is the argument
of this election look David Cameron
wants to say not a minute you asked
about wages you tell was wrong that
wages until I say that for us for all
know you said that I forecast that wages
would fall Jeremy and they did yes and I
was right right they did fall maybe they
will be right on unemployment when you
asked me about wages I don't ask you
three things that make sure three things
unemployment i mentioned wage levels and
i mentioned in from unemployment i was
quoting the Office of Budget
Responsibility forecast as it turned out
that forecast turned out to be wrong but
look let's go to the big picture here
the big picture is of this election do
we think the economy six David Cameron
was on earlier he says things are good
right and things are fine I don't think
things are fine for the reasons that I
set out in the town meeting earlier on
because I think I think we are too much
based on low wages I think work is too
insecure I think our young people are
burdened down by by a lack of
opportunity and that is what's got to
change